let's talk about my boy scott pruett ah
now the left wants you to think that
he's some corrupt grifter using his role
as head of the EPA to milk the
government for every penny it's worth
just because he spends millions of
dollars on personal security and takes
blackhawk helicopter rides to coal mines
but he's not exploiting government perks
look at him on his way to dinner last
night
yeah that's a great car great car gets
negative three miles to the gallon which
is also the EPA's new fuel efficiency
standard see Scott is not the kind of
guy who uses his office only for
personal gain sometimes he does it for
his wife a new potential conflict for
the EPA Administrator Scott Pruett he's
now accused of using a government aid to
help score his wife eight chick-fil-a
franchise crew it had his
taxpayer-funded staff asked about a
business opportunity for his wife the
idea according to the post was for
Pruitt's wife to operate one of the
restaurants franchises yes
getting his wife a chick-fil-a is
adorable we all know the 10-year
anniversary's 1015 is Krystal and
apparently 25 is mostly white meat with
a couple pickles but just like
chick-fil-a evangelical agenda the story
keeps going the shameless media has been
hounding Scott all month Pruett ordered
thousands of personalized office
supplies that includes twelve silver
personalized pens with the EPA seal and
Pruitt's signature on them for the low
low cost of more than fifteen hundred
dollars now that breaks down to one
hundred and thirty dollars per pen
believe it or not oh okay okay
$130 may sound like a lot but these pens
right in crude oil quill baby quill and
then there was this Pruett used his
staff his official staff to run personal
errands on the taxpayers dime such as
finding him an apartment to rent or
personally tour the properties even to
call a Trump International Hotel in
Washington to see if he could buy a used
mattress
ah yes the very best adjective to
proceed a mattress use followed closely
by you know your mom and I actually
created you on this don't believe the
hype don't believe it he's a good man
not some con artist if you were really
abusing his position he would at least
try to hide it this this is as exposed
as that secretary who showed ankle to
Mike Pence you say there's something
else going on here if you look close
enough chick-fil-a that's basic
sustenance mattresses just a place to
sleep
pens tools to write new laws Scott
Pruett isn't swindling American
taxpayers no he's creating a second
purse now sure he's not done
he'll probably add a form of currency
and a taxpayer-funded moon Porsche but
Pruitt is making earth too which is good
because let's face it our planet is
getting toasty for some reason someone
should look into that opposers are there
any three words more exciting than click
and subscribe
yes Hillary shot Lincoln subscribe now
and find out the truth they don't want
you to know and by day I mean losers
looking for YouTube handouts without
clicking subscribe do it